because when you say unattended market
what does that mean exactly it's some
specific language that means I mean
let's take let's take access to finance
for example people who are excluded from
access to financial services on with
these people being these would be
generally very poor people often in in
rural but also semi urban or peri-urban
areas who are discriminated against or
excluded on the base of physical
location on the base of literacy on the
base of inadequate physical records on
the basis of lack of land holdings
ten-year assets collateral on the basis
of gender and so by so for example
peasants in Peru or a tomorrow or grad a
borrower's or for example Sudan outside
of outside of chrome pen in Cambodia and
you have a vertiginous drop-off in rate
of access to finance because there are
physically no branches there and
depending on how that oscillates with
mobile telephony you either will or may
or may not be hooked up to evangelist to
digital take take some of some of the
investments that I've made in the past
but we've invested in in in financial
institutions that are aiming to provide
additional services to to the poor both
in volume and type so not just access to
basic loans but also perhaps micro
health insurance micro-insurance more
generally crop disaster insurance I
believe that there you have to go back
to your language perhaps that capital it
capitalist impulse the investors in the
form that made that investment are
looking for a return but we're also
achieving a new one with social good are
we not and potentially environmental
good when we get into agricultural
financed by extending financial services
to these previously excluded groups so I
think though if I may say the way that
you set up the question is quite is
quite provocative which is great but I
would I would I would challenge some of
the I here sort of marks underneath a
screaming from his grave